each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so so this talk is about
environmentally immersive programming
and at something that we started to the
University of Virginia and recently as I
moved we're continuing to do that at the
University of Illinois why we're doing
this and what saw you know why I believe
it needs to be done well if you look at
where is the course in developing sensor
network systems if you look at one
experience one particular experience I
had and that's what the jacks benkovic
will build this vigil net system at the
University of Virginia with Jax Dunkirk
was the VI and so you can look at what
did the system cost well the hardware
for the system was something like 10k at
most it was a hundred nodes were maybe a
little more and at market prices you can
buy that for you know ten thousand
dollars now the software development was
a really big effort and so if you look
at the most optimistic estimate of what
it took to develop the final version of
the software it took probably at least
five grad students who I would say
worked hard for 20 weeks you know full
time and I guess you can employ grad
students brief my feel free but I put 30
bucks so an hour there for them so i
feel if you multiply that out you get
more than 100 k just developing the
software so essentially software
development is really the big hit as of
course the hard word and hardware is
getting cheap or as programmers time is
not necessarily getting much cheaper so
so we need to solve linear software
development problem on it to make that
easier cheaper and so on what does that
entail well first we need to remove or
to reduce the cost of actually coding
writing down the software and so we need
to structure the code than I agree with
the previous talk in the terms of you
need to really have some kind of
reusable components there in order to
for you to be able to develop
applications pretty quickly you also
have to have suitable high-level
abstractions so that those who actually
write the code are able to write that
easily in and not in an error-prone
fashion another huge cost is debugging I
mean we spent most of our time
necessarily building the software but
really debugging it and so you really
need some automated checking and
analysis tools that are able to find
include pat abilities between different
components and are able to resolve this
in compatibilities another type of
debugging here is it such a performance
debugging because there is a lot of
services that run on in a very resource
constrained environment and you put them
together you'll run them and perhaps you
you don't get fast enough response or
your capacity overflows and you get
congestion and so these types of
performance debugging needs to be
addressed as well so there is a
substantial testing costs involved and
that tasting course needs to be
minimized and the way you would minimize
it is perhaps to do something like M
star or other you know simulation /
simulation environments perhaps
integrate that with your software
development environment so that a
developer can sit program through these
high abstractions and then have an
analysis engine that would say well here
are my sort of performance requirements
on the system with this quote satisfy
those requirements and then there is a
collection or a mix of analytic
techniques and simulation based
techniques that come back and say well
you have bottlenecks here and you're
likely to have problems there and you
have incompatible assumptions between
these types of modules please fix that
and that will hopefully you know reduce
the cost of developing software so we're
trying to build a system that would
address these issues okay now let's
start with the first level which is you
know the high level of abstraction and
there was a lot of work on making
distributed programming or programming
to a distributed environment easier now
that worked traditionally focused on
abstracting communication for example
and distributed system and providing
things like location transparency okay
so a lot of the traditional Carradine's
for distributed computing if you will
address these two items now we believe
that a sensor network that alone is not
enough because the main function of a
sensor network is to understand
something about the environment and that
that is why it's programmed that is why
code is written and so the cord should
somehow be revolving around
environmental abstractions directly that
would simplify and make it more logical
for the programmer to conceive of what
needs to be living and how it needs to
be done so essentially in a sensor
network we really need to represent we
need to have a computing paradigm that
would represent the physical world in an
easy and intuitive way to the programmer
who actually writes the code to access
that world and facilitate the
distributed interaction facilitate
writing or coding the distributed
interaction between the sensor network
and in its environment okay so you can
think of an environment like in that
picture here and perhaps every object
that is being sensed in that environment
is represented biological object in the
computing system these logical objects
will make it easier for the programmer
to assign tasks that need to be
monitored about them or or or how they
should coordinate so there's been a lot
of previous I mean there's been a lot of
effort on writing different types of
high-level abstractions high-level
programming abstractions and this is a
partial list I haven't really updated it
but there's been several of these
languages what I'm going to talk about
in this dog is something we call in
virus suite where the focus is on
abstracting the environment and
representing physical objects in the
environment biological objects in the
computing system and if we believe that
that is a reasonable of section of one
of many reasonable abstractions well
what are the challenge isn't actually
implemented okay what are the challenges
of building a programming system around
it so so to repeat the abstraction we
want to want to present this new address
space we want to present this new
address space to the programmer where
the adjustable entities are in fact
representation of physical things and
the environment now this physical things
could be you know a target tracking
applications could be for example
targets you know cars driving around and
you want to represent each one by an
object in your computing system if it's
something that collects data from a big
region maybe that region is the object
and and you want to refit
somehow the state of that object maybe
you have multiple regions so you have
multiple region objects in a ubiquitous
pack of computing environment perhaps
the objects are self-identified so maybe
this room is an object and maybe people
are walking around with RFID is and they
self-identify that I am you know person
X and that would be an object and then
you can operate the on these objects and
for example find out which room a
particular person is in ok so that is
the idea we have this context they have
some kind of logical representation they
have a unique name these contexts are
instantiated dynamically when say in a
tracking application a car drives into
the environment the the system should
generate that object dynamically for the
call and you can attach computation as a
programmer you can attach methods that
would execute in this context and and
and that's how you build your your your
application suck it so essentially built
a system that does or begins to do these
tasks and that system is composed of
several parts the first part is kind of
a user interface so that so the user
rights in this new language which is in
virus sweet and these declarations are
translated into application code which
in this case is actually written in SC
it also gets translated the whole lot of
library calls that do various things on
infinite various types of support
protocols for representing different
types of objects let's see we need that
interface there are a couple of levels
of abstraction so at the very low level
we abstracting away the sensor data
processing protocols so even the
simplest answer is like magnetometers
for example or light sensors or distance
sensors many have you know outputs that
are you know pretty sophisticated
sinusoidal waveforms and you need to
mind this wave force for certain
patterns to do for example realize that
you have a emotion hit in that hit is in
fact a large target and not for example
small target so so there's a lot of work
that's been done on doing this
types of data processing on the modes
and for example there's a paper by
accidental contact on census 2005
there's also you know things like this
micro cameras you'd you you do get
visual feed from the environment but you
don't actually send those frames out you
represent them by a by a very kind of
concise representation and so so this
interface above this layer is really
very concise it's it's it's a short
representation of and such a complex
phenomena that's been filtered up and
that comes from multiple sensors
dynamically at runtime now every type of
object now in virus suite has a taxonomy
of the typical objects that you might
encounter in the system and as we
encounter more applications we can
extend that taxonomy so as I mentioned
before I give examples of tracking
objects or your track you know something
that is a localized but moving into it
in an Indian in the environment you have
region objects which is something very
diffuse and so on the presenting these
objects requires different types of
protocols so for the tracking you will
have protocols that support migration so
that your your you get to track your
state gets to track the object because
that is moving for region objects but
has it's going to be some kind of a
three formation protocol so every type
of object will have its own
representation protocols in the invited
sweet system and that's what these
protocols are also we don't necessarily
assume that we have a base station so it
could be that the data that is generated
needs to be locally stored but it needs
to be locally stored in a way that we
can find it later so we need distributed
storage system where we can operate
disconnected for a while but then lets
you put a base station the base station
can suck up all the information in a
meaningful way or perhaps somebody can
walk into the system with a PDA and
communicate with the nearest north and
be able to find out what had happened in
the system when it was disconnected that
also requires a communication system and
it sits on top of the regular burkas
so that is the you know I'm a kind of a
small summary of the main components of
advisor sweet there is also an analysis
ancient because like I said one of the
things that we're trying to do is to
facilitate the performance analysis so
that the program i can say look here are
my performance requirements can I can I
really meet that and so the programmer
would specify base there is an analysis
engine that would interact with my
protocols and be able to say something
about whether or not performance is
likely to be met or not and that may
also interact with a simulator so I am
able to develop the squad compile it and
then simulate it on something like the
awesome right now the awesome is not
necessarily representative or
performance but it made me some idea of
a single work okay so what this achieves
is I have now been able to transport in
a programming task from the level of
writing please distributed protocols
which are very error-prone and something
that the programmers typically don't
like to do transform that into writing
aggregate things and I'm going to talk
about the programming model so
essentially i'm going to be saying
things like track vehicles in a high
level of abstraction and that will get
translated into all jacked so that's the
tracking object i know the protocols to
do that and I know what type of sensory
data I need to use so the programmers
life has been easier the programming
codes much shorter hopefully it's less
error-prone and I have analysis tools to
make sure it's correct so let's look at
more at the language this is really more
of a preprocessor rather than a
full-fledged language because we do
write in this year but we augment messy
with the ability to declare new types of
objects so there is this extra set of
declarations that the programmer writes
upfront and this declare context softer
of the program's perspective what they
write are the types of context and I'm
going to talk about what that means and
the type of state that they want to
collect in each context and so this
context perhaps would be for you know
objects of different types so here
example of a context of type car in the
context of type you know human and they
would be defined by different sensory
signatures so at run time when the
compiled invited sweet runs on the modes
whenever the modes find that the sensory
signature matches the idea of one of the
objects that they learn about from the
compilation a corresponding logical
representation is constructed and then
from the programmer scored the
programmer has defined what types of
methods run in what contexts so these
methods are automatically instantiated
in that context ok now this methods may
may work on certain state that again the
program are defined so that it's
collected within the skylift there may
be multiple objects that exist together
and so there are inter objection
primitives that allow the programmer to
to exchange information so in for
example can count course now note that
the way that would be implemented it can
also work even if the system is
operating unattended and disconnected so
it doesn't have to have a base station
of the have any base station would help
but if if there's no base station it can
still survive and then when the system
gets connected again the base station
can suck out the information that was
stored in the system while it was
disconnected now this is a pseudo code
of just to give a hint at what would it
take to write a context so essentially
you specify two things let's say you
want to specify a context record for
this car just specify two types of
things one is the sensory signature what
it is to be a car and in a state what do
you do when you see a car so this was
you know the origins of this started in
this doctor project where we were
checking vehicles and people in the
desert and so perhaps if something is
moving in the desert that's already a
potential problem and and if it has a
magnetic signature then that probably is
a vehicle of some sort and so maybe both
and these are complex functions so this
is not necessary
really i mean this is this is a complex
signal processing algorithm for haps the
trans on the most so that describes the
signature now everybody who matches this
signature will say well maybe i am
seeing a car so let's form a group we
form a group elect a leader and this
leader starts collecting data about the
car which type of data that is what the
state function specifies so in this
example it collects location and
particular the position of the sensor
that is reporting the event and and you
can associate some quality parameters
like i can say that i need at least
three sensors to tell me there's a car
in order for me to believe that it's a
car and perhaps I need them to report
that within the last two seconds so
there has to be frequent current within
the last say two seconds or kind of
freshness parameter in order for me to
remove false alarms that defines the
context and it defines what beta is
encapsulated it doesn't define what a
silly to do with this data so that's
when the programmer writes objects and
attaches these objects to the contexts
okay that's done a compile-time so so
this generates the compiled program that
gets distributed on the most to
summarize the programmer writes two
types of entities in the context of the
objects the programmer tendon attaches
objects to context and they can
communicate and so at run time when the
objects of the sensor network knows how
to identify are found in the environment
the nodes automatically form the logical
representations of those things and by
able to exchange information
yeah so that's where if you feel noticed
in the beginning I i had this box on the
side the first analysis and so that's
where that box can say you know you need
at least five sensors given the
assumptions that you're told me about
the environment that's right that's
right that's right that's right so in
this case for example if ya if you put
the sensors far enough apart that if a
particular time there's no more than two
that are that are seeing the target and
you said I need at least four to believe
wheel then you never got to see any
targets so so what you don't have for
example things like the probability you
can you can compute the probability that
the sensor is going to give you a false
alarm yeah yeah that's right
yeah so what happens with actual invite
record is that it does return you know
saying okay I I have seen the target
then there are three sensors and and so
you if it's if it's below your threshold
of say four sensors in order for me to
believe you then you can choose to do
not believe or even choose to believe so
it basically turns both numbers it says
you know here's an object that you
requested with I want four sensors for
it but I got only thing that lets go the
object okay
so that was a wave torn from the
programming model now each type of
object has a sort of object
representation protocol and let me give
you a brief hint of an object
representation protocol for you know the
tracking object now what does the object
representation protocol actually does
what it what it does is first of all it
has to ensure uniquely presentation if I
see one card and there are five sensors
that has seen the car I I should still
report one card and not fine so so there
are protocols to ensure unique
representation it's a little bit harder
is to ensure identity management if I
see two cars in busto course crossroads
you know cross cross paths other make
are gonna make sure that that I actually
associate the right identity with the
right car after they have crossed and at
and for certain types of sensors that is
simply impossible but but that is one of
the challenges one thing that is good
about half and predefined protocols to
do these things is that you can have
fixed semantics you can understand
exactly what these protocols will do
when there are crossing targets you can
understand a little bit more about false
negatives and false positives and you
can understand a little bit more about
how this protocols will be for example
object boundaries so one of the
advantages of using the system is that
you have used you are using protocols
that have been pre-tested and that have
been associated with certain
similarities welcome you can rely on
when you are building systems on top of
them now this protocols would need to
find the multiple categories depending
on what type of objects they are
representing and and let's take an
example of jacking cars so the actual
protocol the two years for jacking
objects is that whenever a bunch of
sensors sense the object so you have
specified what what it means to sense
the object whenever that is true this
sensors will form a group and elect a
leader this leader will then broadcast
and say I I have seen an object of a
particular type and I have given it an
ID and here is the ID so now everybody
within a slightly larger radius knows
about the object
later on one of these yellow nodes might
service red nodes imagine these are the
ones the seed object now the yellow
nodes are the ones that know about it
from the leader if one of the yellow
guys later sees the objects themselves
they are not going to create a new
representation for it because they know
that it's probably the object that they
just heard about from the nearby leader
so that reduces the problem of creating
spurious objects for the same physical
entity it also turns out that there is a
limit on how fast that external entity
can can move without creating spurious
representations so the intuition is that
if the external object moves too fast
then it's going to be detected by
sensors that are so far enough apart
that they cannot realize they do not
realize that they seem the same thing
okay whereas if the external object
moves slowing up then it's easier to
recognize that we are all seeing the
same external energy okay so so we are
able to quantify what that maximum track
above p it is okay there are all kinds
of open questions in how to ensure
unique representation of these things
you know how how how does that unique
representation depend on object type for
example are there any fundamental
limitations so for example if you look
at unique representation it's something
like a consensus problem we'll have to
agree that we all see the same thing and
so there are there may be some
fundamental limitations with achieving
these types of consensus among nodes at
runtime and so how you know can can you
know the runtime system automatically
verify that a unique representation will
be achieved or not now let me give you
very briefly another result so this
isn'ta analysis so I'm shifting gears
from sort of the unique representation
of objects in the physical environment
to something that we can say about the
relations between through port for
example energy consumption and delay so
in general a programmer must specify
performance
quirements and I need an analysis engine
that is able to tell me whether these
performance requirements can be met and
I'll mention very briefly at the high
level what exactly that analysis tool
does so that analysis tool thinks of a
sensor network as a cloud in general at
the brothel kind of bird's eye view that
cloud deceives or consumes energy to
convert events into some kind of
actionable information and in doing that
it takes time and so there are really
three fundamental axes in this formula
one is the axis of time the delay takes
to process the information one is the
energy and one as the sort of throughput
how much output I can get out the
network and so we would like to quantify
in order to do an attack of optimization
we would like to quantify what are the
fundamental trade-offs within that space
ideally I would want infinite
information and zero time with zero
energy but that's just not possible so
the question is or what is possible okay
where are the boundaries of what is
possible in those in that
three-dimensional trader and so we've
looked at that boundary in a particular
we looked at the boundary between
throughput and delay and I'm going to go
through this very very briefly but
essentially we ask ourselves the
question that if you have some data in
the network that is time sensitive and
it needs to get to the edge of the
network or two to a base station within
a particular amount of time how does
that time relate to the throughput that
you can get out and how does that change
if you have say multiple flows with
different time constraints so
intuitively their ability to get out of
the network in time decreases if you
increase the packet size the length that
you travel or you're essentially if you
increase the amount of data if you
increase the length that you travel or
if you decrease the latency constraint
that decreases your ability to actually
meet the lady city street and so your
ability
to meet the latency constraints is
affected by this factor and it turns out
that this factor has a bound if this
factor is less than that bound you are
able to meet your latency constraints if
it's above that bound then or bets are
off and so we quantified that bound for
different types of networks okay so this
would be an example of such a bad and
what this does is that value can be late
all kinds of network parameters like
path length you know how many
collections points you have what type of
radio you have to throw put but you get
and to Layton sees that you get and this
would be something that the analysis
tool can help you with so if you get a
very very rough back-of-the-envelope
calculation of whether your network is
our provisioned on the provision that
has not enough density or what and i'll
probably stop here just mention that we
have in fact deployed the larger system
that was composed of this tracking /
invite in wire suite plus a lot of other
services including time synchronization
power management and so on and that was
part of a DARPA demo so since everybody
had a picture I have a picture too and
we were able to track things in the
environment working person running
person vehicle another vehicle and you
could see tracking results there so it
trusts are relatively accurately so to
summarize what I what we are trying to
do is answer a bunch of open questions
such as you know what are the right
abstractions for high-level programming
for sensor networks that would reduce
the development costs and what are the
type of layers that should sit
underneath that abstraction okay sensor
networks live in physical time and space
and that creates those spatial temporal
constraints and so what is the right
equation what is the right way to
analyze the fundamental spatial temporal
constraints that exist in a sense
and the fundamental trade-offs between
various various properties like timing
throughput energy and so on and you know
generally what are the right tools that
would reduce the cost of things like you
know development you know validation
testing deployment and execution of
sensor network systems that's what
advice which is hopefully trying to
achieve that's it
I I think i partially agree with you the
one thing that might come into the
picture is that in the modes that we've
tried there is a very very high degree
of false alarms even after processing so
you do a local person you still get
posted arms you know to give an example
you know modes have this antenna and
when the wind shakes the antenna the
magnetic sensor goes off when it rains
the motion sensor goes off and so on and
so at some point you can send all this
data to a base station but you can save
some energy by just locally in many
cases if you just ask a couple of
neighbors you can realize that the
supposed to learn so so that level of
processing which is local to one hop but
not necessarily you know if the base
station is not within that hopped and
it's not necessarily at the base station
can help
okay yeah so actually I want to go back
to the point with priorities one of the
things that we are doing now is trying
to build essentially a mac and drafting
layer that does prioritize data so that
so that we optimize some notion of
utility rather than some wrong notion of
throughput and in terms of the running
multiple applications that's that's
something that needs to be addressed so
right now we are able to simplify the
act of programming the application but
it works best if you run one application
at a time and download it
that's right
that's right so so the way we went about
it so I sort of agree in principle in
principle that the application domain
expert is the one that knows the most
about these types of parameters and the
uncertainty is about different objects
in models and particular models of for
example when you know this pan cannot
make a 180 degree turn this way and so
right now this is sort of embedded as a
module as a sub module of the tracking
protocol which which can be swiped in
and out and so in some sense if I go
back to this picture not the same
the other picture here so part of this
tracking protocol would be the model for
the tracked object and so you can change
that module we can we can make it into a
first-class abstraction so that there's
an easy interface for that but in the
current system who haven't done that yes
what it means to track right now the
jacking protocol is fixed so you you
have to choose your step tracking
protocol but then you're sort of magic
to it while the system is tracking yeah
so you can update so so basically this
is not to eliminate the deployment costs
there will be a deployment course
hopefully you will live in the field for
say three days instead of a week or two
weeks to be to get the system to run and
that that's what we're trying to sort of
reduce